après plusieurs journées d'autobus
exténué ils arrivent enfin dans la
capitale américaine
ces migrants hispaniques qui sont entrés
par l'Arizona ont été mis dans cet
autobus par les autorités locales ici
ils sont plus d'une centaine en
provenance du Texas à avoir été déposé
juste devant la résidence de fonction de
la vice-présidente
la seule destination disponible à partir
du Texas dit semi grand c'était
Washington un sacré pied de nez
politique de la part du gouverneur
républicain du Texas Greg Abbot
une crise causée par l'administration
Biden dit-il qui laisserait rentrer trop
de migrants
refusant de gérer le flot de migrants
sur son territoire il a été le premier
il y a quatre mois à envoyer presque
quotidiennement des autobus remplis dans
des villes démocrates comme Washington
New York ou 12000 migrants ont été
relocalisés mais aussi au Massachusetts
il nous envoie ces migrants sans nous
prévenir dès le gouverneur de l'Illinois
le gouverneur du Texas dit la
porte-parole de la Maison Blanche ne
fait que créer le chaos avec cette
mascarade politique pour juguler la
crise la mairesse de Washington vient de
créer au coup de 10 millions de dollars
un bureau d'accueil pour les migrants
de migrants ne cause pas trop de
problèmes pour les services de la ville
ou sans abris
Tatiana le bord dans l'organisme
accueille les migrants depuis quelques
semaines pensent que le chemin de
certains d'entre eux ballotés de ville
en ville n'est pas terminée
vont continuer leur route vers le Canada
car ils ont été traumatisés en seul
américain
en attendant dans cette église de
Washington des bénévoles sont prêts à
les aider
tout ce qui font c'est pour une
meilleure vie pour leurs enfants ils ont
traversé des montagnes vérifièrent des
parcs ils ont eu des parcours très
difficiles de tout ça pour leurs enfants
croyez-moi Claudia Gomez est heureuse
elle va héberger sa nièce qui vient tout
juste d'arriver du Texas un cas plus
facile à régler mais pour des dizaines
de milliers d'autres migrants
s'éloignent d'être terminé